أه أريد أن أحذر مشاهدينا الآن
ما أنت على وشك رؤيته هو رسومي
للغاية وبالتأكيد مزعج للغاية ،
فلنكن حذرين فقط تحرك ، تحرك
من الطريق ، إنه مثل مشهد من
بوابات
الجحيم يتناثر الموتى عبر هذا الطريق السريع
غربًا  من kiev
لا يزال البعض بجوار حطام مركباتهم
بينما تتجول الكلاب بحثًا عن البحث عن
هذا ما تركته القوات الروسية وراءها
عندما انسحبوا من هنا قاموا
بنصب كمين هناك حيث نحن
ذاهبون الآن يخبرني ألكسندر راتزيكوفسكي
أن هؤلاء كانوا مدنيين قتلوا بالرصاص
من هذا الموضع حيث
وضع الروس دبابة ويمكنك أن
ترى أنه في الواقع يبني
منطقة إطلاق النار التي تراها نعم وهذه
السيارات تبدو وكأنها في طابور
لا توجد سيارات هنا لأنهم
لن يسمحوا لهم بالحضور لقد أظهروا
للتو  يقتربون من الحكومة الروسية
وينفيون استهداف المدنيين
الذين يسمون هذه المزاعم نقلا عن مزيفة
ودعاية لكن الكسندر جزء من
وحدة طائرات بدون طيار وقاموا بتصوير أحدها.
كانت الحادثة
في السابع من مارس عندما كان الروس
لا يزالون يسيطرون بشكل كامل على هذه المنطقة وكانت
مجموعة من السيارات تسير على
الطريق السريع الذي استداروا فيه بعد
أن أطلقوا النار على ما يبدو من موقع الدبابة
توقف هذه السيارة وخرج السائق
ثم قام هذا برفع سيارته.  رأسه فوق
رأسه وفي هذه اللحظة يجب أن يشتري في
هذا المكان
قتل شخصان في ذلك اليوم ماكسيم
يوفينكو وزوجته زينيا التي كانت
تجلس أيضًا في السيارة
وأكدت العائلة هوياتهم لـ CNN
بعد الحادث الذي قامت فيه الطائرة بتصوير
وصول القوات الروسية
خرج شخصان آخران من السيارة وأخذهما
بعيدًا كان ابن الزوجين البالغ من العمر ست
سنوات وصديق العائلة الذي كان يسافر
معهما ، وأكد الأقارب أنه تم
إطلاق سراحهما لاحقًا من قبل
الروس ، ثم فتش الجنود جثة ماكسيم
وسحبوه بعيدًا في
هذه الحادثة.  كنا مصدومين
ومحفزين لوحدة الإسكندر للطائرات بدون طيار في
الحياة الطبيعية قبل الحرب ، كنا
مدنيين نحب الطيران بالطائرات بدون طيار
بشكل عرضي وقانوني  لا أحب إنشاء فيديوهات يوتيوب لطيفة ،
لكن عندما بدأت الجائزة ،
أصبحنا في الواقع جزءًا حيويًا
من المقاوم ، أرسل لنا الإسكندر
ساعات من الفيديو يظهر فريقه وهو يبحث
عن المركبات الروسية
حتى عندما يجدها مخفية ويكاد
يكون من المستحيل  بقعة ثم نساعد
الأوكرانيين في ضربهم ، نحن أعين نسميها
الجليد لأنه بالعيون يمكنك أن ترى
ويمكنك الإبلاغ وبمجرد أن ترى
يمكنك شن غارات
جوية بالمدفعية كم من الوقت يستغرق لإيصال
معلوماتك إلى الأماكن الصحيحة
ثم تكون قادرًا على التصرف بناءً على المعلومات الاستخباراتية
التي تقدمها في الوقت المناسب ، فهذا
يتعلق بمسألة
دقائق وأحيانًا يمكن للبعوضة الصغيرة أن تقضي
على قطيع كامل من الأفيال ، هذه
لقطات من طائرة بدون طيار لوحدة الإسكندر
تبحث عن عمود ضخم من
الدبابات الروسية والمدرعات
المركبات وهذا هو العمود بعد أن وجدته الطائرات بدون
طيار ، أخبرني الإسكندر أن وحدات
مثله لعبت دورًا رئيسيًا في صد
القوات الروسية على الرغم من أن الأوكرانيين
كانوا على نطاق واسع  نحن متفوقون على قدرتنا على المرونة
كمشجعين إقليميين ، يمكننا ألا نريد
أن نرحل تمامًا كما لو كان ضررًا انتحاريًا ،
لكن الجيش الذي يتعين عليهم البقاء
فيه يأمرون بالبقاء ويموتون فيه ،
لكنهم يبقون ويحملون
لا أحد يعرف عدد الروس الذين لقوا حتفهم هنا ،
لكن المجموعة تقول إن الكثيرين قد تم القضاء عليهم
بمساعدة مجموعة من الطيارين الهواة بدون
طيار الذين يتطلعون للدفاع عن وطنهم